[Music]
i want to teach you something
something i haven't even told my sons
i have a lot of sense
thunderbolt can be anything
thunderbolt
it's just electricity you can have it
anytime you call power is everywhere you
just have to harness it
now you point
[Music]
power comes from the heart
like the romans said
april
open your heart
[Music]
open your heart
yes
vanity
is at the edge of space
you go
and you go until you can't go no further
there you will find the altar of
eternity thunderbolt will take you there
sure you won't come with us we could
really use the king of the gods no no no
no
to go there
you must be pure
zeus
is many things
but he's not pure
good to go
yeah
how are we getting there
[Applause]
there's the maniac who seeks to end us
all
and putting together the greatest team
ever are you packed
yes
valkyrie this is the best day of my life
yes they are they also scream quite a
lot
you said this would be a relaxing
holiday
i said it was going to be like a
relaxing holiday
[Music]
you